el mes de julio anunció un contundente
paso hacia el turismo espacial por el
momento sólo reservado para millonario
ya no son sólo los estados los que
buscan mostrar su poderío atravesando la
atmósfera ahora la batalla la encarnan
los multimillonarios ya pesos y richard
branson mientras que besos dejó su
puesto en amazon para centrarse en su
nave espacial que según anunció sería la
primera en llevar turistas al espacio
branson se le adelantó diciendo que su
cohete despegará el próximo 11 de julio
he estado esperando esto durante 17 años
sólo me permitía emocionarme hace dos o
tres días cuando el encargado de la
ingeniería me llamó y me dijo que todo
estaba listo
la misión fue nombrada como y unity 22 y
el equipo estará compuesto por tus
pilotos y cuatro tripulantes en los que
estarán brand son un astronauta un
ingeniero y la vicepresidenta de la
compañía por su parte se espera que la
nave espacial blue origin télex llegó de
amazon despegue el 20 de julio a bordo
irán besos junto con su hermano la
piloto veterana de 82 años world y funk
y cuatro pasajeros más que participaron
en una subasta millonaria para poder
abordar la nave sus nombres aún no han
sido anunciados llevo trabajando en esta
nave durante tres años es una nave muy
grande es tiempo de volver a la luna
pero esta vez para quedarnos en el
turismo espacial sería sólo el primer
paso para que ideas como la del sí o de
tesla elon musk de fundar una ciudad en
marte ya no parezcan tan lejanas por
ahora queda esperar para saber quién
será el primero en lograr una misión
autofinanciada rumbo al espacio